[Musique]
le watergate l'immeuble historique en
plein coeur de washington
un rappel de ce que le journalisme
d'enquêté a déjà été
ce quatrième pouvoir qui faisait
trembler les élus
[Musique]
c'était les années glorieuses mais
depuis l'arrivée d'un certain président
la presse a perdu un peu de son lustre
de marque faith in est un journaliste
dans quête de renom il enseigne
aujourd'hui à l'université du maryland
si watergate était arrivé aujourd'hui
dit il je ne pense pas que nixon aurait
démissionné
vers médiatique est tellement polarisé
que la moitié du pays il aurait soutenu
quels que soient les faits
l'as neudorf ni a directement été
impliqué dans le scandale du watergate
il est l'ancien grand patron du
washington post
les voix qui ne veulent ni entendre la
vérité ni les faits dit ils sont de plus
en plus forme de fac sauveur forte aussi
sur internet et son lot de nouvelles sur
les réseaux sociaux chacun choisit sa
nouvelle son information peu importe la
véracité des propos il faut juste
qu'elle soit conforme à notre opinion
trop d'américains acceptent des
mensonges dit il veut vraiment sont
celle que wade n'a pas vraiment
remporter les élections qui les a volés
que l'assaut du capitole était organisée
par la gauche
c'est plus facile de s'isoler dans un
amas de mensonges que ce l'était ya 50
ans g
les ennemis du peuple a martelé pendant
quatre ans dans notre chambre qui aura
réussi à diviser même ébranlé un pilier
même de la démocratie américaine
nous voyons des candidats en campagne
électorale dit-il qui veulent museler
les médias il reste cependant confiant
sur l'avenir et sur pour le journalisme
dit il à moins qu' un régime autoritaire
jon rauch automne giallorosso et cette
possibilité n'est plus écartée avec le
spectre du retour de dans notre chambre
[Musique]
malgré deux tentatives de destitution
contre l'ancien président et malgré
l'assaut du 6 janvier au capitole choc
continue à être populaire chez les
républicains
aujourd'hui le washington post est une
équipe qui couvrent spécifiquement la
menace à la démocratie
non
ce soit en 2017 le quotidien adopte un
nouveau slogan de marcoussis guys and
darkness la démocratie meurt dans la
noirceur
j'enseigne à mes étudiants d'être
préparé dit il
que des gens vont les accueillir et les
traiter d' ennemis du peuple ils doivent
se rappeler qu'ils sont là pour informer
le public
un 50e anniversaire au goût amer car
aujourd'hui ce sont des élus qui veulent
voir s'effondrer ce quatrième pouvoir
qui résistent tant bien qu
il ya des blogueurs qui serait du canada